[Music]
if royalty had a rock star Marie
Antoinette was it the famously excessive
last Queen of France who met her fate at
the guillotine was a notorious for her
love of luxury now part of her opulent
lifestyle is going on sale I think she
probably was one of the original you
know the original it girl
honestly in terms of her style and her
relationship to fashion and and jewelry
jewels that belong to Queen Marie
Antoinette are being auctioned by
Sotheby's next month the pieces were
smuggled out of France before her failed
attempt to escape the Revolution and
include a monogrammed diamond ring with
a lock of her hair earrings and a rare
drop pearl with a starting price of 1
million dollars
we estimate them based on the value of
the jewel and then we see where it goes
from there I think Marie Antoinette is
gonna hold the same allure now that
she's held for over 200 years and I
think we're gonna see some strong prices
take those drop earrings Christmas is
soon coming